m
[Musique]
peux-tu détendre ton
triangle de tristesse
[Musique]
sais-tu ce que les gens regrettent sous
leur lit peux-tu allumer le téléphone
non non non mais ils travaillaient trop
sept personnes sur dix
soufflaient
[Musique]
une idée que j'avais  avec le film quand je le
faisais, je serais également
méchant avec tout le monde dans le film, peu
importe que vous soyez pauvre ou riche, je
les traiterais
de la même manière et je
les défierais de la même manière
parce que je voulais éviter un cliché selon lequel
cela  c'est que les gens riches sont
ignorants et égoïstes et que les pauvres
sont spirituels et
généreux,
alors il vaut mieux
regarder que notre comportement
change en raison de la position que nous
occupons dans une hiérarchie financière
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
h
[  Musique]
euh
[Musique]
c'est aussi une grande année pour la Suède, je veux dire
pour nous, c'est important parce que
nous voulons aussi montrer à nos collègues
cinéastes qu'il est possible de faire ça
pour venir au plus grand festival de cinéma
du monde et gagner,
c'est incroyable
[  Musique]
toi